welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home's
biggest multiversal cameo just went from
purple haze vape puff to just one out of
fifty shades of confirmed with dakota
johnson playing the blind clairvoyant
with the best gaming chair but also a
character associated with the broader
spider-verse whatever your thoughts are
on johnson playing this role looking
closely at those purple cracks reveals a
solid audition as the blind badass
to me what's most interesting about this
is how a madame webb movie actually
moving forward frames how we're meant to
interpret the way spider-man no we home
left the multiverse both in the sony
spider-verse and the marvel cinematic
multiverse of doctor strange and the
scarlet witch yes it's a complex and
intricate web being woven by these
studios and i'm gonna break down why
interconnected universes where madame
webb exists is an awesome concept by the
way you can see me and the other new
rockstars host talk about this stuff
live in a special live show in chicago
this friday february 11th 8pm italia
hall ticket link in the description so
if you're like me well first off i'm
sorry that you lived that existence but
your first introduction to madame webb
came in a 1996 episode of spiderman the
animated series make a wish in which
madame webb appears to spider-man as a
mystic medium from another dimension
with power over realities on the level
of the beyonder she's voiced by joan lee
the wife of stanley and madame webb test
spider-man from across the multiverse in
order to try to find a champion to stop
spider carnage from destroying the whole
multiverse but madame webb first
appeared in a 1980 comic the amazing
spider-man 210 as the clairvoyant medium
who initially uses her psychic powers to
help peter parker stop other crimes
defining the truth of spider-man's
identity as peter parker that knowledge
may be why madame webb appeared as one
of those purple silhouettes and no way
home earlier on the train in the mirror
dimension doctor strange said in the
multiverse there are an infinite number
of people who know peter parker is
spider-man madame webb is one of those
people born cassandra webb and salem
oregon she suffered from myasthenia
gravis a neurological disorder that
causes her to become paralyzed and blind
but she develops psychic abilities her
husband jonathan builds her special life
support chair cybernetically infused to
her brain evoking the form of a spider
she becomes a new york area medium
advertising herself with flyers since
you know new york is a teresa caputo
town in the comics cassandra is often
depicted passively bound to her chair
kidnapped by the juggernaut at one point
later on joining norman osborn in the
gathering of five ritual that luckily
grants her immortality then later on she
de-ages herself to her younger form and
joins a few of the spider women in order
to try to stop her granddaughter the
third spider-woman and then later on she
gets kidnapped again by the family of
craven the hunter in a plot that ends
with cassandra transferring her powers
to julia carpenter the second
spider-woman making julie carpenter the
new madame webb that lives on in the
ultimate spider-man animated series so
cassidy and dakota johnson may signal
that they might be pursuing the julia
carpenter's spider-woman madam web
incarnation with someone else playing
the older cassandra web doing it this
way might give the currently spider-man
less venom and morbius universe a spider
hero could also just be that dakota
johnson could be playing a younger
cassandra web we'll see but the more
recent comics series and games have
really explored the concept of the web
of life and destiny a three-dimensional
construct of five-dimensional space that
connects the full spider-verse together
this is where madame webb derives her
clairvoyant abilities actually we
learned that all the spider-man variants
drive the more magical parts of their
powers and their spider senses from this
same multiversal source coined as
arachno frequency peter's tingle his
ability to detect danger moments before
it comes is part of his link to others
including the much more powerful
clairvoyant madam web and ever since
that 1996 episode with joan lee fans
really see madame webb as a cosmic
sorceress who transcends realities and
now in the live-action spider-verse the
ultimate elder and adult in the room who
could have explained to the three peter
parkers all the villains and doctor
strange how all of those realities
really fit together this is why we need
her in this multiverse and hoping we do
get an idre garfield amazing spider-man
3 or another toby mcguire film madame
webb is the cosmic authority sony spider
sorcerer supreme to provide the logical
framework through which all three peters
can continue to coexist in fans minds
now sometimes i stay up super late
finishing a video and then i want to
sleep in but all the electric lights in
our lives make it hard to get a bedroom
totally dark but that's where the blue
blocks remedy sleep mask comes in handy
we knew blue blocks from their blue
light blocking glasses but their sleep
mask goes farther and blocks out 100 of
light for better sleep it's very soft
and has these adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap for the perfect fit it
works for belly sleeper side sleepers
and back sleepers they're made from a
very breathable material and you can
fully open your eyes while wearing it
where am i i'm in a dark nebulous face
and i'm home this feels so perfect just
leave me here to float
we all float down here wait what it's
just really great for improving sleep
and meditation and napping and travel
and just general life outlook i love
using it when i want to sleep in or grab
a nap during the day they ship worldwide
and they have other great products like
red light therapy devices so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars and use a
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
that's blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com new rockstars and use a coupon
code new rockstars to save twenty
percent no way home showed peter parker
in his astral form still able to
unconsciously control his physical body
to keep that mackinac decadavis away
from doctor strange the wavy lines
judging out from peter's head confirmed
that he is using the spider sense to do
this and we don't know if peter could do
this before this was the first time his
soul was detached from his body but it
was one noticeably enhanced application
of his spider sense in that movie that
along with that creepy long shot of his
ability to sense norman osborn's
betrayal well before norman presented
imminent danger might indicate an
evolved spider sense relative to past
films due to his eracto frequency being
compounded by other spider-man currently
sharing his universe again magic rooted
in the same source as madame webb's
clairvoyance and i think the reason sony
is announcing this madame webb casting
news now and defying many fans
expectations by casting a younger star
as a figure more commonly seen as an
elder matriarch is that their
partnership with marvel studios and
spider-man no way home has paused at the
moment and in the minds of many fans
those events will be succeeded by
another huge crossover event in doctor
strength and the multiverse madness the
questions about the multiverse posed in
no way home will be answered solely by
marvel studios through mcu sorcerers
like doctor strange and the scarlet
witch wanda maximoff leaving sony
without a seat at that table and so sony
may feel they need their own authority
on how this overall multiverse logic
will affect the spider-verse branches of
that webbing a mystic being that they
feel is on a similar level as elizabeth
olsen as wanda maximoff an ambassador
from one corner of the multiverse to
have a seat at that table and
potentially form a companionship with
the mcu scarlet witch friends maybe
frenemies but at the end two cosmic
witches who can check each other's
powers so that when the earthbound
heroes and villains from alternate
realities all face each other in future
crossover events like avengers secret
wars or yeah maybe sooner and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness if
toby mcguire does come back to cameo the
spider heroes through madame webb would
have their own cosmic representative and
authority within this hierarchy to help
explain how for them this all takes the
form of a web and life and destiny that
unlike those other variants like the
backstabby loki's over in the mcu corner
of the multiverse we spider variants are
blessed to be connected on a shared web
based on cooperation and trust so is
dakota johnson the best person for that
role i mean i don't know i don't know
exactly what chapters of cassandra's
life this film plans to tell but judging
from her work in movies like the lost
daughter dakota johnson's an excellent
actor i think we all just need to do a
better job trusting actors to do their
jobs to transform to the needs of the
role rather than immediately write them
off based on how we knee-jerk typecast
them from their past work like folks if
we can trust edward from twilight to be
batman we can give a chance to the star
of the story based on twilight
fanfiction to be our multiversal spider
witch check out our great merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
the rockstars and subscribe to rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you